hello I'm Joel Pedone a Dean of the Yale
School of Management and one of the
faculty who's been involved in the
design of the faith and globalization
seminar at Yale University I'm pleased
to have with me here John Thornton John
is a professor at Xinhua University he
is the chair of the Brookings
Institution board and he is the former
chief operating officer of goldman sachs
john thank you for being here with us
thank you good morning John as you know
one of the central themes of the seminar
is the relationship between faith
spirituality and religion on the one
hand and economic development on the
other and a country that is a very
interesting case study in that context
is the country of China a country both
through your work through your teaching
and through your extensive efforts to
actually bring the United States on the
one hand and China closer together you
you certainly know a lot about I'd like
to just begin with sort of open-ended
question and ask as as you given what
you know of the political leadership in
China today how do you think they are
thinking about the relationship between
religion and spirituality on the one
hand and their country's economic
development on the other well I think we
have to answer any question on China in
a in an overall context and remind
ourselves of at least two things number
one as a external observer
I always feel a great sense of humility
trying to get my mind around exactly
what the Chinese leadership thinks and
exactly what the Chinese culture permits
or encourages so with that strong caveat
I'd also like to put in context the
overall economic growth so for 30 years
trying to be growing at nine ten percent
a year never before achieved in history
and
the economy needs to grow at 7% per year
just to create sufficient jobs for the
new entrance into the workforce
therefore there's kind of a red line is
7% that the leadership clearly doesn't
want the country to go below now because
of the history of China which is to say
periods have come followed by periods of
violence and because of the recent
history of China particularly the
Cultural Revolution and the current
leadership very aware of that many of
them having lived through it and rather
dramatic ways I would say priority
number one two three four and five for
the leadership is stability now within
the context of stability and very
related to stability is the issue of
economic growth
however as as the country moves forward
and as more people come out of poverty
and as more people experience a new
level of economic existence it's both
natural and in fact I see it in my
students at Xinhua I desire to ask the
question well wait a minute what is my
life all about what is it I'm trying to
do why am I doing this and searching for
a deeper meaning to their existence now
and I think that's kind of organically
going on in the minds of most people and
I think therefore there's a kind of
unspoken void of sorts that needs to be
filled and I think the Chinese
leadership is aware of that most
recently you may have seen that the
president of China the current president
who Jintao has been a proponent of the
so-called harmonious society this is a
term of art that the Chinese leadership
uses as a kind of I would say a kind of
aspiration as well as a
a sort of working hypothesis now it's
intentionally left vague as to what it
means so that you and I can put our own
meaning into it I personally think it
has quite self-conscious Confucian
overtones to it that it reaches back to
the notion of harmony as Confucius
understood that word who Jintao has
never said that that's my own
interpretation and I think it's also a
sort of a it's a concept that can apply
to the very poor rural farmer where an
effect you're saying to that person your
principle or a principle purpose as a
member of this culture of the Chinese
culture should be to contribute to the
overall harmony of the society and
therefore you should be doing nothing
that would contribute to disharmony and
on the other side if you are the young
35 year old by Chinese standards very
wealthy entrepreneur it says to you you
have an obligation or responsibility to
contribute to the harmony of society
anything you do this dis harmonious is
not in keeping with the culture and
therefore you should be behaving in a
way that is not ostentatious that is not
exacerbating the differences between the
rich and the poor as you as I'm sure you
know China now has a disparity in rich
and poor that's very much like the
United States and this is a professor it
was clearly a problem so with that
overarching theme and I think also a
clear evolution towards increasing
amounts of personal liberty and with the
official recognition of religion by the
by the Communist Party and by the
leadership
I think what you're seeing as a general
matter is an increased willingness on
the part of the leadership to allow
religions and/or spiritual people to
wooden use the word flourish but I would
say to be part of the building of a more
pluralistic society and however going
back to rule number one that the first
five priorities are stability stability
stability stability stability and having
regard to the harmonious society notion
it would say that you must conduct
yourself in a way that is doesn't
threaten stability and is harmonious
those two those three things presumably
being if not synonymous very consistent
and therefore as a kind of matter of
prudent advice as an individual I think
you would be you'd be smart to keep your
spirituality as a private matter which
is why you've seen from time to time
when movements have arisen like felon
gone which and I'm not a felon going
expert by any means but I think most
proponents of Helen gun would see it as
a sort of spiritual movement when that
movement when one day thousands of
members of the movement showed up in
front of John and I the central
leadership compound that was seen as
some kind of potentially organized group
that could in some sense threaten the
the Communist Party and therefore was
shut down pretty severely so so the
trend is pretty clear
now on the other hand I wouldn't from
that necessarily jump to any particular
conclusion if you go back into Chinese
history you'll know that Buddhism
Confucianism Islam Christianity have all
played their part in Chinese history
some more than others and some I think
would be regarded now is more indigenous
than others
and the vast majority of Chinese people
I think would see themselves as if they
saw themselves as spiritual it would be
in some sense different than our
distinctive from what we in the West
would regard as spiritual and so I'm
loath to or I'm reluctant to take this
general trend towards increasing
personal liberty and say therefore it is
likely that spirituality will merge the
way it has exactly okay there's a number
of themes and what you just said so let
me sort of pick up on those themes and
ask you ask you about each of them the
first is this trend that you've noticed
in your students this and and in society
more broadly this desire to find meaning
the second is the is the concern with
stability stability stability on the
part of political leadership in fact
that spirituality seems like it could
simultaneously fulfill fulfill both and
then the third is a distinction that
comes out of what you've just said and a
distinction that it sounds like the
political leadership even if they
haven't articulated it this way are
probably sensitive to which is the
distinction between spirituality on the
one hand and then an organized religious
movement on the other and then the
fourth is the fact that spirituality
seems to have a way in which it's
starting to arise may have some
reflection of what we see in Western
countries doesn't necessarily mean that
that's where one should assume it should
go because they have a different history
so if I take those four pieces and I'll
ask you about each first this search for
meaning that you're seeing in your
students do you see that as being driven
more strongly because of the economic
changes or has it always been there
and they're now being allowed to reflect
on it or think about it in light of the
other forms of liberalisation that are
going on in the country
I don't truly know the answer but Mice
and mice my intuition is this that most
of my students are young when I say
young average age is mid to late 30s so
I have students for eighteen and I have
students who are 45 and everything in
between so most of my students have by
definition because they're Chinua
they've done very well on their
examinations national examinations
they've gotten in changhua one way or
another they're successful in the
society and they probably have some kind
of job either they've just come from or
going to or they're still in which is a
some kind of high level job one sort or
another so it's a particular let's call
this group the people who are clearly
benefitting right now from from them
from the economic progress in China so I
Mayan to ition is that they that as they
have succeeded and maybe in particular
my class because my class encourages
this question encourages the question of
what were you going and how are you
getting there and why are you doing this
I think they've simply started to
realize that almost as a matter of
responsibility
well the personal responsibility and a
societal responsibility they should have
a kind of a worldview and how they fit
into that worldview and they should
understand very carefully who are they
what motivates them what are they trying
to achieve and why and in answering all
of those questions I think you
inevitably get to the most fundamental
question which is what does it mean to
be a human being where why are any of us
yeah in the 21st century I'm thinking in
particular and I think also this is
probably brought into sharp focus
because if you step back yet again and
you ask yourself where's the 21st
century going and just to take one
example if China continues to go down
the development path that it's going
down now let's call it the Western
development path
the best numbers I've seen show that
China within 20 years well or 20 let's
say around 2030 something like that the
per capita income on a purchasing power
basis will be the equivalent of the per
capita income in the United States today
so if that were the case and the Chinese
let's say broadly speaking behaved as
Americans did or Western developed
countries did then for every four people
you'd have three automobiles which means
you have one point 1 billion automobiles
today in the world we have 800 million
in total China would be consuming 100
million barrels of oil a day today in
the entire world we produced maybe 19
million barrels a day so this one
country China you know most every
feature and dimension would be consuming
more than the whole world does today now
if you follow that logic and you then
throw in and what India might be doing
or Brazil or Russia or Indonesia let
alone where the United States develops
in Western Europe you quickly come to a
view that this doesn't work and
therefore you need some kind of new
model which the Chinese leadership is
conscious of and so when you go down
that path and you say what does that new
model mean what does it look like
you can quickly come to the question
what does it mean to be a fulfilled or a
successful person does it mean is it a
consumer society you know I was reading
a bit of a Marin history the other day
in the 17th 18th century and noted that
around that time the leaders in this
country told people or encouraged people
to think that consuming was in and of
itself as social good and to this day
American policymakers will tell the
Chinese you need to get your people to
consume more if you would do that would
be good for the world economy which
undoubtedly is correct but it does beg
the question it where's it written that
consumption is dipso facto a good thing
and where's the balance here between
what you consume and how you consume it
and how its manufactured
and so forth so it seems pretty clear
that a new model is going to have to
evolve now that new model in my own mind
isn't just for China it's going to have
to be for the rest of us and that's
going to be quite dramatic change so in
that context coming back to the question
of spirituality I think you do come full
circle because you start to think harder
and sort of redefine or put different
emphasis on what it means to what a
fulfilling life looks like it's not
simply it's really not just a
materialistic and at the moment that's
where the Chinese society seems to be
heading and it's not just a
materialistic and then what is it and
what is it that gives people deeper
satisfaction so so in the u.s. the
sources of those models would be
religious leaders they they might be
people who we'd put broadly under the
rubric of social entrepreneurs
developing developing a model create
creating a constituency for that model
and then trying to get that model into
the public sphere for dialogue debate
and and hopefully at least for that
entrepreneur it would it would it would
it would spread um how does that happen
in China I mean when I go back to what
you were saying about the harmonious
society it sounds like this is a
dialogue that takes place within the
leadership that sort of gets tried out
and they wait for reaction and see how
it plays out modify based on that
reaction is that is that how it works
yeah I think the Chinese leadership for
some time have had this notion of sort
of what I'll call big ideas that every
so often get put out and initially when
they're put out they are relatively
ill-defined and there's kind of an
unspoken conversation that goes on and
sometimes that conversation is very
vivid and very very animated and very
energetic and you can see it and hear it
and sometimes it's more subtle than that
but
the conversation takes shape over time
and and then the leadership sort of
refines the concept or the concept
becomes an effect in effect collectively
refined so for example just a few years
ago the Chinese leaders have referred to
China's peaceful rise which was another
kind of term of art and is that that
particular term was debated among
intellectuals in particular both
intellectuals on the left and the right
disliked it because on the one hand the
ones on the Left said rise peaceful rise
why are we why are we using a term like
that which might circumscribed
our ability to behave in foreign policy
terms they might in effect be a form of
unilateral disarmament and you had
intellectuals on the right saying this
word rise this word rises to threatening
we should use this word rise so
eventually peaceful rise morphed into
peaceful development and now that term
of art still exists so with harmonious
society I think when it was first put
out there many people were sort of
somewhere between particularly
Westerners I would say we're sort of
dismissive of it this is kind of a form
of propaganda doesn't mean anything etc
I think actually is this lived on it's
taken on greater force because as I said
a minute ago I do think there is
increasing clarity of understanding that
simply going down the western road won't
be enough and with there's attention
because the Chinese have lifted
depending on the numbers somewhere
between 250 to 400 million people out of
poverty in essentially 30 years which is
quite an extraordinary achievement and
virtually everyone in the country will
know someone in his son or daughter or
aunt or uncle or somebody has done very
well and so therefore the hundreds of
millions who have not yet been pulled
out of poverty are sort of hoping and
assuming they will be pulled out of
poverty and so the Chinese leadership
have got to deliver on that but on the
other hand they've got to deliver on in
the way that's that's good for the
overall it was a very very tough
tasks which also circles back to why
stability is so important because they
say to themselves we absolutely it's
absolutely essential that we have
stability in order to give us the
luxuries or or the room to maneuver so
that we can make some of these
trade-offs that we're going to have to
make in a way that that works so if you
had been teaching your class in the US
and you had been asking your students to
sort of question you know what's their
purpose why are they there what what do
they want to achieve you would be I
assume expecting hoping wanting that the
students would be sort of looking out to
the you know many sources to help guide
them through that answer in China how
important is it that the that the
leadership worked through the model for
your students to be able to come up with
an answer that they feel comfortable
about well let me give you two of two
thoughts on that both my students and
also the ordinary people let me start
with a second first there is a woman
professor she's actually professor of
media at a at a Chinese University who
did her master's degree on Confucius and
in the past two years she's gone on
television sort of a kind of a Chinese
equivalent of a a form of Oprah Winfrey
let's say she's on television talking to
ordinary people about Confucius and
their relevance of Confucius to ordinary
people in ordinary circumstances it sort
of Confucius for the masses and she's
also put out a book and the book has
sold 10 million copies that have been
acquired been bought and ten million
that have been pirated the best-selling
book in China now that tells you
something it tells you I think that that
ordinary people are looking for someone
to come along and give them a framework
of some kind that helps put their life
into some larger context
now for my students who are by
definition part of the elite they I
think it's much more complex because
they have access to and they are hungry
for information from all over the world
almost all of my students are are good
English speakers most if not all have
traveled quite extensively or have
traveled quite extensively they are in
veteran users of the Internet so they're
looking all over the place and and and I
think that kind of exuberant or
energetic experimentation is going to
continue for a while and therefore with
the Chinese leadership so is only some
things that you were talking about which
was pride as opposed to the focus on
clear and the clear one solution in the
values spirituality and having a model
of self here gives me very very hungry
there's much more concern about
organized religion and and again for the
exact same reason about its concerned
because of the potential impact that it
can have on on stability I mean if I if
I put those two together it sounds in
some sense like in China the the the the
evolution of of people's spiritual
selves will be based more on this
country level dialogue than on any
actual action I mean if I can be a
little bit self-deprecating mean sounds
kind of like an academics paradise right
I mean it sort of like we'll just sort
of keep talking and when we get it we
get it as opposed to you need to build
churches you need to build organizations
you've got to think about you know what
what do you have to have in place in
terms of interests is that is that yeah
well first of all I would say I'm sure
it I just don't know enough about this
but I'm sure there are individuals who
have in their mind what might be called
a conventional model and they're
involved with a specific church and that
church is building itself out across the
country and so on I'm sure there is some
of that going on
but I would say in all my time in China
very rarely do you run across someone
unless you seek that person out who in
the ordinary course of talking with you
or even in a more detailed in-depth
conversation that I might have with the
student as I'm mentoring him or her very
rarely will they come straight out and
say you know I'm a committed Christian
and I'd like to talk to you about that
now there are some like that I have one
student for example who whose parents
were in the government he was in the
government and he literally says that he
was walking down Park Avenue one day in
the early 90s and he had a revelation
and right there on the spot he decided
to leave his government job he went back
to China he left his job and he started
a business which manufactures Christmas
trees electronic Christmas trees which
he sells through Walmart to make enough
money to come back and go to Yale Law
School to study constitutional law to
return to China to have an impact on the
work on the development of the rule of
law but that's one student out of let's
say 500 I've taught in the last six
years now there are a fair number of
students or friends who are buddhists of
one buddhist of one sort or another when
I said one sort or another I mean
varying degrees of spirituality as
distinct from kind of an ethical
framework which is part of their makeup
but even there this is not a topic that
they would typically volunteer this is a
topic that you would you might get into
because you sought it out so and I think
part of this is just cultural that
cultural in the sense that the Chinese
culture isn't the kind of culture the
word that would be volunteers it might
be in certain other cultures and part of
a cultural meaning the society is
developing and so that what's
permissible and what sort of convention
is is evolving and so I think it's
correct my point might find a kind of a
prognosticator I would guess that
there'll be another quite a few years
well this
station we've been describing is taking
place well at the same time certain
things are happening within organized
religion which is probably in some sense
reinforcing that conversation or feeding
into the conversation and and a lot will
depend on how those organized religions
conduct themselves do they I mean you
could if you wanted to be wanted to be
expansive you might even say that the
that the strict separation of church and
state might evolve for a very different
reason in China as it did here and
what's what's what's permissible in the
public square and what form and and how
organized is it and I think just to make
one other footnote you've also seen the
Chinese leadership I think try harder in
dealing with organized religion such as
the Catholic Church in trying to come to
some some kind of accommodation I'm sure
you know that there's been a kind of
free zone between the Chinese and the
Chi Catholic Church for a long time
which has started a thought and I think
the Chinese in general have taken the
view that it's in China's interest to
engage in dialogue and reach some kind
of harmonious state whether that's with
other state actors or other other
institutional actors and there are only
a couple of issues that are kind of sort
of non-negotiable or no-go areas where
therefore the review is crystal clear
and it's black and white and can't be
transgressed but other than those few
issues there general operating
philosophy has been to reach out to
people institutions and states in order
to create the conditions under which
they can govern the society which is
itself such a complex task that they
can't afford the distraction effect of
dis harmonious relations with anybody so
so so one last question you and I have
talked before about China one of the
things that you have commented on is the
the very long time horizon that the
Chinese leadership
for those who would be observing China
would be interested in the way in which
the dynamics around spirituality and
religion would unfold what's the time
line they should be thinking about to
get some kind of indication as to to
where things are going would you expect
in the next two years that things could
change in a significant way five years
ten years no let's see the way I think
about this I mean one one marker I spent
a long time researching and ultimately
writing a piece on political evolution
in China and in effect what that piece
said was that in my judgment some time
in the fifth generation of leadership
the Chinese since the Revolution first
generation was now second generation was
done she'll paying third was Chun
semaine fourth as our current leadership
of jeantel so the fifth generation idea
the next leaders would who come into
power in 2012 and then they're in power
for ten years so from 2012 to 2022 my
piece on political evolution essentially
said my guess is sometime in that time
period we'll start to get a clearer
sense of where political evolution is
really going and wherever it's going
it'll be distinctly Chinese and put a
little trend towards trend towards a
Western democratic model I think in
parallel that will be issues like this
question of spirituality it'll be there
for two reasons one because I think the
leadership will see that spirituality
can be a congealing force and
necessarily a a force which works
against the stability of the state it
can be a congealing force and also a
force in some ways that can moderate
other more potentially pernicious issues
like nationalism like unbridled
nationalism which the Chinese think of
to always have to be on guard for so I
think they will realize that and I think
also they'll just generally become
increasingly pluralistic and recognized
that's part of the texture of a of us of
a 21st century society that's
thing and so I think in there will be
this as when to watch for this but there
will not be and my judgment anyway there
won't be a kind of a time where it goes
from we turn on a light switch it goes
from from dark to light it'll just sort
of be slowly coming out of the out of
the ether all right well done thank you
so much for sharing your thoughts
sharing your insights and for
participating in the seminar once again
I'm Joel padule-- and have had the
pleasure to have conversation with John
Thornton thank you thank you